d'abord qu'on voit une femme il faut le
considérer comme son égal
je vais avoir tendance à republier à
mettre en story tout ça des comptes que
je suis et qui me plaisent et qui je
pense enfin revendique les idées
importantes et après je vais aussi aux
manifestations quand on a et que je peux
y aller
je pense qu'il faut avant tout
sensibiliser les plus jeunes le modèle
que je lui donne dans la vie oui c'est
le respect de tout le monde des hommes
des femmes des animaux voilà on est tous
on est tous à égalité on a tous le droit
à une chance et puis oui j'espère que
j'espère que les générations futures
font en sorte que que ça fonctionne
cette petite fille et que c'est cette
petite fille que je vois régulièrement
et avec qui je discute de de leur avenir
ainsi de suite j'essaye de leur faire
comprendre que rien n'est interdit
qu'elles peuvent tous envisager
du coup je pense qu'en ce 8 mars
il faut tous se mobiliser que ce soit
les hommes ou les femmes parce que le
féminisme il doit aussi être porté par
les hommes des droits des femmes tout ça
je pense que c'est un combat qu'on doit
tous mener c'est ce que ça devrait être
une évidence aujourd'hui mais ça dépend
encore malheureusement les filles je
pense que vous êtes très forte je le
sais faut pas être seul il faut pas se
renfermer faut croire en elle je fais de
des droits des femmes pour chaque femme
du monde